à l'époque les
angers caen aventure les appels
temporaire notre aventure touche à sa
fin iris la buse elliott nos trois héros
ainsi que thomas ont enfin récupérer les
trois reliques et partent vers les
cordes n'est laissée par le docteur
simon je suis trop pressés que vous
entendiez la fois vous allez voir c'est
ouf c'est calme nous sommes dans la
banlieue de mela en 1997 température 17°
pluie fine mais je pensais que le futur
ferait plus rêver malheureusement ce
sont les années 90 à l'époque la plus
chiante de l'humanité c'est peut-être
ici en fait l'infiniment en moyens d
acné tonnes y à rien tout ce chemin pour
ça pourquoi mon père nous a menés
justice il faut consacrer
ça fait au moins deux heures qu'on
discute ça fait vingt secondes en
pensant sulfurique
c'est pas ce truc c'est tout ça il a
peine à ouvrir les yeux cette déchirure
à wingles ans devant nous m'a tout l'air
d'une faille spatio-temporelle népal est
quoi et quelqu'un à l'intérieur n'ont
pas regardé en tout est là parce c'est
mon père on a trouvé mon père bonjour
monsieur sommes enchantés vous
rencontrez moi c'est thomas le pick up
c'est bien le docteur simon au fond de
la faille
ils essaient de nous dire quelque chose
nous entend pas allez on y va
c'était donc j'attends santé maastricht
je sais pas ce que c'est le partage
c'est parti
j'ai grâce la valeur dangereux jpp
l'histoire non elle pousse pas
qui sait vraiment où l'on partout où ils
sont nés iris tata qu'est ce que tu fais
là tu toi kb 28 je suis heureux de vous
retrouver docteur simon vous m'avez
appelé à la rescousse et j'ai apporté
votre fille elle est comme une soeur
pour moi vu que vous êtes comme un péché
qui eux ont chanté monsieur je me
présente sur la buse je vous tu m'aimes
pas parce que mes amis me l'ont demandé
mais pourquoi la faille s'est refermée
c'est bon t'as pas honte à retrouver et
on a récupéré les bolides comme tu nous
la demande pour un les balises retour
vous savez enlever les balises au tour
mais c'est pour ça qu'il a failli se
refermer
pourquoi vous avez fait ça mais si toi
qui les a placés pour qu'on les récupère
ce sont des objets qui nous relient papa
des cadeaux qu'on s'était fait pour
prouver qu on était une famille mais pas
du tout
j'ai pris des objets au pif à la maison
des trucs qui pouvait ressembler à des
reliques pour que personne ne touche
jamais j ai inséré des balises pour
assurer mon retour et vous savez tout
foutu en l'air on ne pourra plus jamais
sortir décès
tucat comprend quelque chose la
situation est délicate précision on est
dans la merde pourquoi vous pensez que
je laissais caché à des endroits très
précis et que j'ai demandé aux gens sur
place de les protéger
sans elles la faille se veut ferme je me
disais bien que c'était bien gardé ses
balises à récupérer à un moment j'ai
même fallu faire la remarque mais comme
il y avait des conquistadors qui
essaient nous tuer savez les sorties de
la tête alors je vois c'était une
triangulation multi temporel fixe pour
maintenir la faille avait exactement
astucieux kb 28
tu ne pouvais pas le comprendre avant
quand ça vous arrange je suis une
cafetière mais tout d'un coup je fais
une erreur de jugement sur un procédé
qui relève de la mécanique quantique et
je vous déçoit ses pairs le faire
semblant d'avoir tout compris
t'inquiète je fais ça tout le temps à
temps les reliques n'avait rien à voir
avec moi je pensais que mais pourquoi tu
m'expliques jamais rien tu m'a jamais
parlé
t'as jamais lever le nez des machines de
fonctionner mais pas du tout au
contraire
iris si j'ai fait toutes ces recherches
pour trouver cette faille c'est parce
que quand tu es né je me suis rendu
compte de la valeur que tu avais j'ai
voulu maîtriser le temps pour pouvoir
remplacer plus souvent avec toi mais tu
aurais pas pu tout simplement passer du
temps avec moi dès le départ la logique
du docteur simon se tient mais je
préfère largement celle d'hier istres de
toute façon on a tout le temps
maintenant puisqu'on les bloquer
ensemble ici dans cet espace vide pour
l'éternité
qu'est-ce qu'on fait chasser on fait
comme quand les pirates découvre une
nouvelle ils ont rappelé cet endroit non
non je suis la seule femme
j'ai joué entre un pirate un robot mon
père et mon ex alors on n'a rien rappelé
du tout dr simon voilà c'est pour vous
dire que j'ai traversé toutes ces
épreuves pour vous dire que votre fille
la poussière au [ __ ] j -pierre dans
une faille temporelle qui donne tu es
aliénor la reine du moyen-âge c'est
précisément ce qui vient de se passer
c'est fou ces fonds qui m'avait poussé
des centaines de fois par la fenêtre
je me souviens tous apprécié ça c'est
derrière moi jusqu'à ce que je sois
explicite cette boucle et machiavélique
est qui apparaissent ici piller chier je
suis défait du fou je suis venu qu'est
ce que vous a fait encore fait ben
disons qu'on s'est amusé à pousser
éclair d'une fenêtre 247 fois jusqu'à ce
qu'ils disparaissent du temps sinon il
aurait continuer encore longtemps le feu
y est ma fureur et ses 1 140 et c'est
deux fois plus grande
le temps est clair en super guerrier
sans cette couleur jaune est en bataille
et mais qu'est-ce que vous avez foutu on
est coincé dans une faille temporelle
avec un éclair démoniaque
c'est vraiment comme ça
un peu foutu la merde jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai été plutôt jadis dans ma vie mais
là je vais être là quand il peut être
encore plus les gens admirent et ceux
qui m'assurent dire demain
ouah
les boules de feu
le feu avec massa les bras
pas
et de renvoyer bergues où le salé
piratage vous allez être surpris mais je
me suis un peu stupide je n'imaginais
pas du tout finir ma vie comme ça mais
ça donne faim des calculs solution
optimale disponibles d'ailleurs j'ai
trouvé comment les sortir de cette
mauvaise passe
regardez mon plan ah oui j'allais
oublier la machine de la haine si on
prend deux machines à voyager dans le
temps et qu'on fait ça mais oui bien
joué qu'à mes 28 as tu es la meilleure
machine à café
merci docteur adam elliot pour réaliser
ce plan il faut te démonter entièrement
et utiliser des pièces exactement les
machines et les composants serviront à
construire un vortex dans une fenêtre ça
peut fonctionner quoi mme elliott mourir
je vais cesser d'exister mais ce n'est
pas grave j'ai découvert l'amitié avec
toi iris je sais au fond de moi que je
serai toujours ton frère même si tu ne
veux pas être massive et docteur chacun
fait que je vous ai fait a compté pour
moi au niveau microscopique j'ai
toujours écrit papa je t'aime avec les
grains de sucre
c'était mon secret je crois que j'ai
découvert l'humanité auprès de vous tous
j'ai cru que c'était un bug mais c'était
de l'amour
elliott non c'est la seule solution je
mets ta on se revoit de l'autre recrue
de taille
[Musique]
commence à fatiguer ni sagesse sacrément
coriace malgré son déguisement y en a
encore pour quelques minutes pour
construire le cortex appartient dgac
tomates et de plantes toiture est juste
là sans bougies et va porter ça c'est
une mission qu'on doit cesser seule
médaille qui tire des lacets n importe
quoi et c'est sur mon enfance aucun
super sayen chef des lasers avec toi tu
assez choquant c'est par ici
toi j'ai pas coûté un ménagères ils ont
le goût de l'amour tout est en place
le vortex devrait sauver quand tu es ça
peut le faire thomas tiers-temps
prennent pas part ouvre la fenêtre
joli match ouvert et global village où
tout va bien fait là bas mais je n'ai
plus peur des fenêtres nous sommes
coincés ici le pays émaillées de machine
à voyager dans fenêtre ont créé un
vortex hitler tombe à un fait divers
comme dans portal on l'a trouvé
quelqu'un de plus cruel que moi j'adore
ton s'est calmé
comment fort de cinq ans tu vas voir
c'est plus très long
et voilà exactement ces chutes et son
désarroi l'ont fait tomber ici et de
nouvelles chutes et son désarroi
on crée une nouvelle faille et tout le
monde sait qu'une faille dans une faille
c'est une sortie une sortie créé avec le
som d'hitler en général et mon staff
elliott
tu vas nous manquer j'ai connu des
humains - octo allez on y va
aleris ou rentrer immédiatement la
machine cinq minutes papa je vais
déposer de hockey mais ne met pas trop
de temps cette époque me fout le cafard
dirais que c'est le moment de se quitter
à vue avoir mon garçon parfois les
rencontres tu apprennes plein de choses
et avec toi rien du tout à part l'amitié
et je me suis beaucoup amusé ravito va
rencontrer la buse ne change rien sauf
les viols et les assassinats
allez thomas gauvin docteur simon la
buse je vous dis au revoir
tonne t revenir péjoine à ramener ta
petite copine comme quoi le physique
c'est pas important
merci maman rice brad marchand a les
attend monfils a semblé dire c'est quoi
ces poupées cette cage et ce truc très
près je suis parti comme une tare deux
jours il y aura ainsi après j'ai
rechargé une sauvegarde dans une autre
cafetière et je suis venu vous rejoindre
mais on croyait que tu étais mort pour
toujours non je vous ai même dit on se
revoit de l'autre côté tout le monde
croyait que ça voulait dire on se revoit
au paradis non vous bien que mon nom
c'était de l'autre côté de la faille
c'est vrai que vous les humains vous
prenez beaucoup de risques pour des gens
qui n'ont pas de sauvegarde
en tout cas je suis très heureux de voir
que mon plomb a marché mais je crois que
vous avez des choses à vous dire merci
elliott dont thomas assieds-toi sur
cette balançoire en cuir non pas celle
avec des picots voilà écoute je sais
qu'on a vécu des aventures folles ça
c'est clair et c'est vrai que ça nous a
rapprochés
c'est bon je sais c'est fini entre nous
alors pour toi savais pas vraiment
comment ces chiens qui nous intéresse
pas mais je te comprends c'est ce que je
voulais dire à ton père je voulais dire
que si j'avais la chance d'avoir une
personne comme toi dans ma vie aucune
machine aucune invention des cartes
raymond regarde elle si gentil c'est
bizarre nous imaginer vivre ensemble à
avoir des enfants un chien mais ça
n'arrivera pas cj
iris thomas aw un petit lapin qui parle
il est trop mignon
t'es qui toi iris thomas ce à propos de
votre fils c'est urgent j'ai besoin que
vous me suivez à travers le temps
l'avenir de la planète on dépend où un
enfant à quoi c'est parti
et dans un instant la suite de l'
aventure de roche déconne c'est la fin
de la saison
c'est ce qu'on appelle un cliffhanger
qui est ce lapin que s'est il passé
entre iris et thomas dans le futur
qu'est ce qui menace la planète
autant de questions auxquelles les
scénaristes n'ont aucune réponse
et ils sont pas dans la merde pour une
fois je sais pas tout j'ai hâte de vous
retrouver pour la suite de l'épopée
temporel merci d'avoir écouté le dernier
épisode de la première saison de
l'épopée temporel merci beaucoup
n'hésitent pas à ta bonnet et à mettre
un pouce en l'air et moi je te dis à
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos et
pour la prochaine saison
angers
une grande aventure les appelle c'est
et encore elle